le texte date de l'année 1867 son titre
une élection dans le grand duché de
gérolstein une satire politique qui vaut
à son auteur un procès en diffamation
menée par plusieurs notables d'ornans à
l'époque des douars ordinaire nous
conservons ces petit pamphlet qu'il a
fait paraître à la fin de l'an pire s'il
n'aurait probablement pas pu le faire au
départ avec un empire beaucoup plus
autoritaire le premier c'est une
élection dans le grand duché de
gérolstein qui est une satire d'une
élection
[Musique]
d'un conseiller général dans le canton
dormant gérolstein étant bien évidemment
la ville d'ornans une documentation
historique précieuse qui permet de
retrouver la trace de cet homme
politique franc comtois qui aura marqué
la lutte contre le régime impérial de
cette fin de 19e siècle l'occasion d'un
deuxième pan fleix rédigé à l'aube des
émeutes révolutionnaire de l'été 1870 et
dirigé cette fois contre les préfets
l'administration règne régente domine
triomphe tous les administrés sont
dociles tous sont muets tous sens bête
[Musique]
alors bien évidemment ainsi vous sous
l'angle de la satire et d'une satire est
très ironique il s'en prend au pouvoir
impérial qui exerce son autorité sur le
pays à travers les préfets qui sont
dotés à l'époque d'un pouvoir
véritablement considérable énorme
puisqu'ils ont la capacité de nommer ou
révoquer les maires un trublion
républicains alors maire de mézières
puis conseiller général du doubs qui n'a
pas de mots assez durs pour dénoncer la
pacotille d'un régime politique qui
osent se qualifié de démocratique
en revendiquant le suffrage universel
masculin maintenu par napoléon iii que
la question constitutionnelle qui est
derrière ces caisses qui fait une
démocratie et que la démocratie exige
bien évidemment le droit de vote mais ne
se résume pas à l'octroi du droit de
vote c'est là toute la complexité de ce
qu'est une démocratie à l'opéra le texte
opportunément intitulé du
perfectionnement de la race préfectoral
vaut à son auteur d'être évincé de sa
mairie de maizière alors que la révolte
couve à paris edouard ordinaire qui
renie de l'histoire sera lui même nommé
préfet du doubs une fois la troisième
république proclamé quelques mois
seulement avant que la grande histoire
n'oublie définitivement cet ami du
peintre gustave courbet ou du philosophe
pierre joseph proudhon il est effacé en
partie parce que il ya une forte
tendance en france tu te faire et de
refaire l'histoire
selon des prismes de vue des parisiens
se dire toute l'histoire locale
régionale et systématiquement effacés
bah par l'histoire de ceux qui sont à
paris ou même comme c'est le cas au 19e
siècle ce qui monte à paris pour devenir
célèbre
l'histoire d'un homme qui a pourtant
compté parmi les figures essentielles de
ces courants politiques et
philosophiques engagé pour la liberté
est dont les réserves de la bibliothèque
d'art chief de besançon regorge on
raisonne aujourd'hui avec notre
actualité sociale